a basement embarrasses Chinatown these
elaborate costumes were meant for the
annual Chinese New Year parade that
draws thousands of spectators but for
the first time the event was called off
this year
suddenly tan who's a regular participant
blames the coronavirus and the stigma
it's fueled certainly no park was the
ride was canceled not out of fear of the
coronavirus but the fear of children
being stigmatized we've been told that
Asian children are coming back from
school crying because they were singled
out and made fun of they were insulted
and called names so we didn't feel like
celebrating it's been very tough Sunday
turn grew up in this neighborhood
a melting pot known for its 1960s
high-rise apartment blocks and dozens of
East Asian stores and restaurants the
Frenchman is of Chinese and Cambodian
descent and says he'd never really
experienced racism openly in Paris until
a week ago was the myth oh yeah I took
the Metro and as I sat down the person
next to me got up and moved away and
then he covered his mouth and nose with
a scarf I realized it was a form of
xenophobia and fear I was sad and
shocked it's far from being an isolated
case accounts of prejudice avoidance and
slurs are piling up in France stoking
unease
here in southeastern Paris the city's
main Chinatown which is home to large
numbers of Frances Asian community the
usually bustling neighborhood seems a
bit subdued many residents are weary of
speaking on camera but some are clearly
rattled by incidents of racist abuse
amid fears of the coronavirus in a
memoir a friend of mine who's Asian was
taunted and called a virus in the metro
that's not very nice our customers
wanted to know if our waiters had
Chinese nationality
even though ours is a Vietnamese
restaurant seeing Asian faces didn't
reassure them this epidemic has really
given free rein to racism against Asians
something which in France has not really
talked about and not taken seriously
the issue was reverberated across the
French media here on the banks of the
River Seine journalist Lynn Landau has
been following accounts by French
issuance of being targeted using the now
popular hashtag I am NOT a virus she is
long campaigned against anti Asian
racism in France but nothing prepared
her for these responses to an article on
the coronavirus in China she translates
into English you shouldn't have eaten
weird beasts this is normal then would
anything in that country the country is
overcrowded - nature is doing its work
this is horrible like people they have
no empathy we're just talking about sick
people and then then we say say racist
things like that
the virus is just a pretext to be
hateful clear said she was jealous Lynne
landau has been speaking out against the
hate on talk shows and on social media
she's also hit out at sections of her
own profession for example for this
inflammatory headline in a local
newspaper warning of a yellow alert so
far France has recorded only a few cases
of the corona virus if the numbers go up
the fear is that prejudice could spread
just as fast as cases of coronavirus
increase around the world so does the
racism accompanying it from across the
globe in
countries as far apart as Australia and
Canada and others in between such as
Malaysia and Indonesia people of Chinese
origin have reported facing
discrimination and verbal attacks all
out of fear that because of their
Chinese heritage they could spread their
virus such as this Australian doctor who
claimed a patient made jokes about not
shaking her hand because of fears over
the corona virus she ended her tweet
with this is racism in Hong Kong a
Japanese noodle shop posted this sign
outside which essentially means we don't
accept people from mainland we want to
live a little longer here in Germany
some people are outraged over this cover
the magazine
- Beagle came up with on the coronavirus
story a journalist reacted to it saying
it was disappointing that in 2020 this
magazine can still come up with such a
cover perpetrating racial stereotypes
here's more on what people are having to
face the following views from the
streets of Paris I was choosing fruit
touching it with my hands and suddenly
this lady came up to me and asked me if
I had the virus I was in shock and I
asked her if she was joking she said she
wasn't she just repeated herself asked
me do you have the virus my daughter
came to me and said mummy at school I'm
being harassed they tell me to stop
coughing - stay away from us you'll
spread the virus it's ridiculous people
have to stop talking such nonsense
my daughter is French she's in France
and she doesn't have the virus their
stories of such discrimination around
the world in Aberystwyth in Wales for
example sue Chu Lu a trader from Taiwan
was told to leave her stall in the
indoor market in the city after she
returned from Taiwan so Chu Lu joins me
now on the line mr. Lu thanks for
speaking to us
who you told when you came back to your
stall in the market it was my first day
back to work after returning from Taiwan
and I didn't expect the matter happened
on me when I won in my store and man
obviously me just asked me to leave the
building and I'm asking why and I he
mentioned it I just come back on her way
and I don't have a few cases of Ravana's
happening there and he told me he said
you shouldn't be in that beauty and
because I might bring the risk everyone
and I have to leave the building
otherwise I'm paid to traders in a hole
but I didn't want to go I say you have
no right to ask me to leave and the he
mention it if I don't leave that
building he will come out a council to
force me
and also he accused me say you went to
China the reason why he said that
because I mention it to one of traders
before I went home for holiday I told
her I might go to China for holiday for
few days but of course when the news of
the buyer is happening in China so we
cancel the trip we didn't go so even I
was trying to explain I didn't go lady
didn't believe me and assuming I has
gone to China
why do you think you in particular were
asked to leave the market for the first
so I they accused me I has gone to China
which mean I already get the virus
already secondly I don't know why they
did it to me because I thought it why
they they asked me to leave because my
identity or because my skin color the
grocer I believe there's so many big hip
hop has by the market hall so wishing
people travel from different place am I
you know am I already in fact by the
virus and there may be the skin color
did for me for did
worried about its little dollies just
only Tachyon me so lots of us make me so
upset and feeling down about this issue
I'm is Lou as far as I understand you've
been at this market for 15 years so
you're not a stranger here is that
correct no less right because I'm a
senior trader in mobility Seoul as well
as make me so upset if I attacked by a
stranger which would mean I can just
take him in and won't be told to be
upset but the trouble is is this thing
happen to me and by the people who I
work so many years so wish me I was
really shocking things to people who are
seeing this and have fears about the
spread of the corona virus what is your
message
well I just would like to appeal to
public we don't need over panic I think
we all should find the virus together
and the most important things don't
bring these fears by attacking Asian
people because that is the virus Pro is
not from these people so we should give
together help each other and respect
each other and there is no need more
attacking on anybody about this issue
miss Liu thank you very much for
speaking to us a virus that doesn't
discriminate based on race so should we
as you consider that here's advice on
how you can protect yourself against the
virus the public advice is pretty simple
but worth repeating wash your hands
frequently with soap and water
alcohol-based hand sanitizers are a good
alternative and avoid touching your eyes
nose and mouth if you do sneeze for
example or cough cover your nose and
mouth with the tissue then throw it in
the bin anyone with flu symptoms should
avoid close contact with others stay at
home if you happen to live in an area
affected by the corona virus avoid live
food markets and contact with animals
and finally avoid speech
in public while largely taboo spitting
remains common in many places and health
officials warn that spitting spreads
disease